anyways welcome to Hannity and we are
back with our live audience uh right
here in in studio uh Texas Senator Ted
Cruz will be here in a moment now today
he helped educate AOC on the sordid
history of the democratic party also
chairman Jim Jordan and chairman James
Comer they will be joining us with the
very latest on their investigations into
Joe Biden Hunter Biden the Deep state
that is protecting them an FBI that has
been politicized and a doj weaponized
also tonight shocking new images from a
woke New York City college professor
look at this holding a machete to the
neck of a New York Post reporter that
reporter will tell the whole story right
here coming up later in the show but
first uh Ready or Not 2024 is heating up
as of right now former president Trump
has a wide lead in the Republican
primary
tomorrow
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis is
expected to officially throw his hat
into the ring during a live event on
Twitter with Elon Musk already there is
a diverse field of qualified interesting
candidates running in the Republican
primary by the way even Chris Christie
is apparently
I think he left office with like a 15
approval rating he's apparently flirting
with another run uh he wants to be the I
hate Donald Trump every second every
minute every hour of every day candidate
and dedicate his entire campaign to
trashing all things Donald Trump all the
time uh do you really think that is the
best use of your time Chris which now
brings us to an important question to
you our viewers at home here in studio
all right so now we have all these
candidates running do you want yours
truly to interview you and give equal
time to every GOP candidate do you want
them to come on radio and TV do you want
to hear from the entire field yes no
okay uh just go to hannity.com you can
let me know we have a poll going on
right now we'll give you an update on
where the numbers are at the end of the
show mark my words this will be a
primary full of ups and downs and
meanwhile Democrats are already circling
the wagons around their 80 year old
corpse Joe fighting even though many
have really serious doubts about his
physical fitness mental ability
cognitive ability even Hillary Clinton
voiced concerns about Biden's age but
Joe's obvious cognitive decline is not
his only problems long story short the
far left staffers that are running
Biden's White House have done an awful
job if you look at every facet of
American life it is now worse under
their idiotic policies their extremism
starting with the border to the economy
to energy National Security Law and
Order infrastructure you name it it's
worse even small things like passports
and visas and permits everything is a
disaster and so far Biden can't even
reach an agreement on the debt ceiling
and maybe that's because he refused to
negotiate with Kevin McCarthy and
disappeared for a whopping 97 days Joe
wouldn't even pick up the phone and call
and he wouldn't accept a call or an
invitation from speaker McCarthy but
don't expect Biden or the Democrats or
their handlers in the media mob to take
any responsibility for anything instead
they'll just smear slander besmerge
Republicans like they always do now get
this today over there at the view that
hard-hitting news show that it is
you had joyless Behar literally trying
to lecture Supreme Court Justice uh
Clarence Thomas and presidential
candidate Tim Scott on racism really
this ought to be interesting take a look
and he's one of these guys who you know
he's like Clarence Thomas black
Republican who believes in pulling us
out by your bootstraps rather than to me
understanding the systemic racism that
African Americans face in this country
and other minorities he doesn't get it
neither does uh Clarence right and
that's why they're Republicans yeah
I know
all right joyless Behar once proudly
posed quote blackface as an African
woman now needless to say it's pretty
weird that she is now berating two
African-American men on the topic of
racism now let's see Clarence Thomas you
need to read his book my grandfather's
son it's a great book uh he grew up in
the Jim Crow era in the Deep South but
joyless thinks that she knows better
than Clarence Thomas Tim Scott also had
a tough upbringing also wrote a great
book about him himself his life his
background and he overcame so much to
achieve his dreams only to be what
dismissed and slandered by a bunch of
ignoramuses over at the view now
everything is woke in this country and
everything's PC in the country except if
you are African-American and you are a
conservative then it's open you know
free game you can say anything you want
and get away with it no penalties no
calls for firing no cancellations no
boycotts in reality Democrats have a
terrible track right record when it
comes to race and equality and the
rights of human beings for example this
morning congresswoman AOC Alexandria
ocasio-cortez asked Senator Ted Cruz to
explain the history of the democratic
party Crews responded quote first it was
the Democratic party that founded the
KKK it was the Democratic party that
wrote Jim Crow laws then the Democratic
party was the one that filibustered the
Civil Rights Act add to this our current
President Joe Biden he was working to
stop the integration of public schools
because he didn't want them to become
quote racial jungles those were Joe
Biden's word words and he partnered with
the former Grand Puba KKK bird as Cruz
also pointed out today Biden also gave
that passionate eulogy at the former
exalted Cyclops of the clan Robert KKK
Byrd his mentor as he called him at the
time and now Democrats are attempting to
use race what a shocker they do it every
two years every four years as a divisive
semi-marxist political stunt dividing
this country you know black versus white
old versus Young Rich versus poor just
divide any way they can generalizing
certain races has Perpetual victims
others as evil oppressors now here's
South Carolina Senator and presidential
candidate well Tim Scott take a look
I do think this is a difference in how
we communicate there's no question that
my life disproves the lies of the
radical left their culture of victimhood
is eating away at the soul of America I
understand Brokenness I understand
having low esteem I understand nearly
failing out of school but I also
understand that we do not live in a
nation of grievance we live in a nation
of greatness
now I want to compare that thoughtful
intelligent message to Joe Biden's pitch
to African-American voters take a look
you decide
you got more questions but I tell you if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black
there's your president anyway so
congresswoman ocasio-cortez uh are you
proud of that are you proud that you're
president the guy that you look up to
that leads your party try to stop the
integration of public schools he didn't
want them to become in his words racial
jungles do you endorse that message or
do you think that maybe it's time for
the Democratic party to finally move
away from its racist Tendencies and
candidates who once supported
segregation and praised as their mentors
former klansmen hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else